el objetivo de este vídeo es presentarte
la idea de los planes de aprendizaje de
khan academy me voy a enfocar en un plan
de matemáticas de álgebra 1 pero lo que
diga al respecto también sirve para
matemáticas de cuarto o para cálculo o
estadística ahora la base de cualquier
aprendizaje es el curso en el que estás
trabajando actualmente si doy clic aquí
en matemáticas de álgebra uno me va a
llevar al curso de álgebra uno de khan
academy para darle sentido al plan de
aprendizaje primero necesitas entender
cómo está estructurado un curso en khan
academy cada curso está subdividido en
unidades
puedes ver la lista de unidades aquí a
la izquierda fundamentos de álgebra
resolver ecuaciones y desigualdades
trabajar con unidades y así
sucesivamente
también las vas a ver a la derecha
aunque aquí están desglosadas en
diferentes lecciones ahora aquí suceden
dos cosas hay un cierto número de puntos
de dominio del curso entero y también
hay un cierto número de puntos de
dominio de esa unidad y en el plan de
aprendizaje hablaremos de cómo puedes
llevar
ritmo a través de estas unidades y
cuáles son algunos objetivos en puntos
de dominio que podrías tener para las
unidades en una semana en particular si
regresamos al plan encontraremos un
texto que explica cómo hacerlo
básicamente presenta el plan y da varias
opciones un plan que puede cubrirse en
20 semanas y otro que puede cubrirse en
12 semanas también menciona qué unidades
deberías estar trabajando semana por
semana y el mínimo de puntos de dominio
que deberías obtener en cada una y hay
un espacio para que escribas al final de
la semana cuántos puntos obtuviste lo
que quizá querrás compartir con tus
padres o profesores y si continúas
haciendo esto durante 20 semanas en este
caso al final de ese periodo tendrás una
buena comprensión de matemáticas de
álgebra 1 al final tenemos algo llamado
desafíos de curso y al principio de este
plan también se menciona que quizá
quieras comenzar tomando estos desafíos
de curso qué significa esto bueno si
estás en un curso y vas a la parte de
abajo aquí verás desafío de curso
y le das click te va a llevar hasta
abajo donde verás que dice comenzar el
desafío de curso y cuando inicies ahí te
dará 30 preguntas que te tomarán de 30 a
45 minutos
estas son una muestra de los temas que
se ven dentro del curso como muchos de
ustedes ya habrán cursado buena parte
del año escolar es un excelente lugar
para comenzar ya que te puede dar
créditos rápidos por cosas que ya sabes
y puede ayudarte a entender las cosas
que no sabes y las cosas que si sabes te
van a ayudar a aumentar de nivel y para
entender lo que significa aumentar de
nivel podemos ir a esta primera unidad
en la que ya comencé a trabajar y
podemos ver que en cada habilidad te va
a decir si tu nivel es familiar
competente o dominado dependiendo de
cuántos de estos bloques hayas obtenido
así que si sabes bastante de un
determinado nivel de grado o de un
determinado curso te recomiendo que
tomes el desafío de curso y se obtiene
70% o más
tómalo una y otra vez esto te ayudará a
acelerar sus puntos de dominio y te da
a créditos para muchas habilidades y te
puedas entonces enfocar en lo que no
sabes y para lo que no sabes puedes ir a
esas unidades en particular y tomar una
prueba de unidad y para que te des una
idea de cómo es eso vamos de nuevo a la
primera unidad si haces clic aquí abajo
a la izquierda en prueba de unidad te
llevará hasta abajo de la página donde
dice empezar la prueba de unidad y ésta
se puede ver como un desafío del curso
pero enfocado sólo en esa unidad
entonces de nuevo si sientes que ya
conoces esa unidad en particular puedes
tomar la prueba una y otra vez vas a
tener diferentes preguntas es una forma
rápida de aumentar de nivel hasta
dominado ahora de vuelta álgebra 1
quizás notas de esto que se llama
desafío de dominio un desafío de dominio
te permite aumentar el nivel de tus
habilidades y pueden ser habilidades que
recientemente adquiriste o te sirve para
asegurar que han revisado las
habilidades que viste en el pasado
entonces de regreso al plan comienza con
el desafío del curso
con la prueba de unidad correspondiente
y en la medida de lo posible trata de
alcanzar los puntos que están aquí pero
si por alguna razón te retrasas no te
preocupes y si por alguna razón no
quieres ir en orden también está bien
todo esto se trata de ayudarte a ti el
estudiante a estar al mando de tu propio
aprendizaje
ahora para quienes se sienten menos
confiados también ofrecemos para cada
nivel formas de afianzar las bases esto
es lo que llamamos el plan súper ultra
poderoso de aprendizaje de fundamentos
para quienes completan álgebra 1 en este
caso y aquí lo que decimos es mira
mientras estás trabajando para terminar
álgebra 1 intenta hacer lo mismo con
nuestro curso de pre álgebra y si eres
un alumno de álgebra 1 que está tomando
el curso de pre álgebra mucho de esto
será un repaso por lo que de nuevo toma
estos desafíos de curso tantas veces
como quieras si obtienes 70 por ciento
más vas a poder acelerar lo que ya sabes
y conocerás en dónde están tus lagunas
para enfocarte en esas unidades
en cada uno de los planes ya sea el de
nivel de grado o el de trabajo en los
fundamentos tenemos planes de 20 semanas
como el que te mostré
y tenemos planes de 12 semanas el plan
de 12 semanas se enfoca un poco más en
lo esencial del curso mientras que el de
20 semanas es un poco más integral
piense en cuál sería mejor para ti y
piensa si lo que necesitas es solamente
el curso de grado o también hacer en
paralelo el trabajo en los fundamentos
pero en cualquier caso todos aquí en can
academy estamos seguros de que si te
mantienes enfocado si sigues estos
planes para el final del cierre de
escuelas ya tendrás unas bases muy
sólidas en matemáticas y estarás listo
para un gran regreso a clases el
siguiente año escolar